[Music]
[Applause]
Dean blandino Fox NFL rules analyst
former NFL VP of officiating we figured
we'd check in with him see if there's
any new rule changes we need to be aware
of what's the one that we need to be
aware of next Thursday so we don't go oh
my god when did they do this
I think the one that I think is might
take some people
a back a little bit is on a kickoff and
it might happen on the opening kickoff
Thursday night we'll see you're going to
see a possible fair catch by the
returner and everybody's gonna go what
why why are you fair catching and
kickoff because you're going to get the
ball at the spot but the rule changed
and now if you if you signal for and
complete a fair catch inside your own
25-yard line the ball will come out to
the 25 so that's a significant rule
change it's designed to reduce the
number of kick returns and I think
that's one we're gonna see we didn't see
it a lot in the preseason but I think
we're going to see it more in the
regular season what about punt returns
if any conversation on reducing punt
returns because I feel like you have as
many injuries if not more on a punt
return than a kickoff that the the data
is saying that look the kick return has
had a higher rate of injury in recent
years that's why the league has gone
toward more of just trying to reduce the
number of returns and I think the punt
is the next play that the league is
looking at and you're seeing you're
seeing more injuries whether it's head
neck whether it's soft tissue injuries I
think they're looking at ways to to to
reduce that because health and safety is
the is whenever you look at rules
changes it always starts with health
health and safety and I think the punt
absolutely it's kick returns then Punt
and punt return
um the league is going to take a good
look at we see these Guardian helmets
and we're using them in training camp
what's the hold up of trying to use
those in actual games no question I
think we're going to see this I think I
and look if it's about health and safety
then and these are used in practice to
limit head and neck the the concussive
blows or something custom blows then I
think it only makes sense to figure out
a way to use them in game and I think
that's something we're gonna see and it
could be in the near future and I think
that's uh you know again it's it's
moving toward helping just eliminate
unnecessary risk for for the players the
uh tush push play competition committee
was split on that issue uh Jalen hurts
uh certainly uh wrote that ran that to a
lot of Success With The Eagles Why were
they split on uh whether they were going
to keep this or not
I think
there are two schools of thought on this
there's there's one school of thought
that look this is this is not illegal
this is a if you can do it the way the
Eagles did it um good for you you know
it's within the rules and they were
obviously successful
um I think there's another another the
other side of that the flip side is you
know again the safety issue you know
you've got all these bodies you're
pushing the quarter back people pushing
from behind defensive players trying to
to get at the quarterback what is the
defense going to do are they going to
start to go low and try to submarine the
offensive lineman
um and it's not a particularly you know
aesthetically pleasing play you think of
the NFL what makes it so great you know
you think of of Lynn Swann and and in in
slow motion making an incredible catch
you know uh in the Super Bowl or things
like that and this is more not that
rugby isn't isn't an incredible game but
this is more of a a Brute Force type
play and the committee was split I think
we're gonna see more of it there were 90
direct push plays in 2022 come compared
to 20 in 2021 so I think more teams are
going to use it and uh and I think the
committee is going to continue to
monitor it we're talking to Dean
blandino Fox NFL rules analyst what
about uh reviewing roughing the passer
rough in the pastor is obviously such a
big call in the game 15-yard penalties
are game changers and we've seen over
the last several years we've seen some
calls last year Grady Jackson on on Tom
Brady which the league came out and said
wasn't wasn't a foul and it makes sense
to to explore if you have this this
technology and you have the video we are
so far away from the original premise of
Replay and I can still hear George Young
when I was a young intern talking about
replay and and talking about once the
camel's tent is is is Campbell's nose is
Under the Tent and I had no idea what he
was talking about but I know now it's
it's once you once you open that door
right it's just gonna fling wide open
and we're gonna start reviewing
everything and I do think there's an
opportunity though with Ruffin the
passer and maybe hits on defenseless
players to find some objective elements
that you could look at in review and get
some of these calls you know there's not
a ton of missed calls but when when they
are incorrect and they do impact the
game so drastic I think you got to
figure out a way to get those specs it
feels like the last couple of Seasons
there's been a point of emphasis that
we're not going to call holding we're
going to call holding we're going to
call past interference we're not going
to what is the point or points of
emphasis you think that refs are going
to be focusing on I think I think
there's a couple I think you know rough
in the past there certainly is one I
think the use of helmet rule is one
where last year there were only four
called all year and this again is a
health and safety rule four calls made
on the field but there were 229 fines
and warning letters combined so when you
think about that Gap okay what's what's
happening in the game where the
officials really can't see this but
we're picking it up on tape so I think
the the league looked at and the
committee looked at that rule they added
some language
um there was language in the unnecessary
roughness rule talking about you can't
use your helmet to butt spear or Ram
your opponent so they added that to the
use of helmet rule to try to give the
officials more clarification
um so I think those fouls will go up on
the field I don't think again it's not
like we're gonna see one a game but when
you talk about a significant player
safety Rule and there were only four not
in a week all year I think that's that's
where the league sees that as an issue
issue and we have to kind of get the
officials more we got to give them more
information so they can make that call
it feels like we're always talking about
the officials they need to be full-time
that this is their full-time job are we
getting closer to that where the
requirement is going to be that you
can't be a lawyer you can't be this in
the offset you you are an official and
certainly with you know the Advent of
gambling of getting the call right and
how much that can that help you get the
call uh you know more correct more often
it's interesting I was talking to one of
our officials that we had in the XFL in
the spring last spring and they were
telling me that this was the first year
where they worked a full College season
they worked the XFL season and actually
worked the usfl season so they were
working almost 10 months 11 months out
of the year and they said that this was
the best they ever felt they felt like
they were on top of it because they were
getting those snaps those reps so it
makes sense officials do spend a ton of
time during the season they are they are
full-time
um as much as anybody else they're
looking at film but again in the spring
they're not out of practice they do go
to training camps they do go to OD OTAs
but maybe it's a couple of days out of
the out of the off season so I think
we're going to see more of that I think
we're going to see a push as we continue
at like you said the gambling and the
integrity and all of those things that
if you're gonna If You're Gonna Want a
Piece of the action the NFL is going to
have to ensure that these games you know
at least even from just an optic
standpoint our officials are full-time I
think that I think it's going to happen
at some point
how does the NFL can the NFL monitor
referees so there isn't an impropriety
that there isn't somebody who got to
them to make a call or not make a call
during a game it's such a big you think
about what happened in the NBA and that
would be a tremendous tremendous blow to
the Integrity of the NFL and the
officiating department and everything
else so there are controls in place and
this goes back a long time as long as
I've been involved in the NFL and I go
back to the mid 90s
um there's there's companies that work
with the NFL that monitor they monitor
the betting lines they monitor how lines
are affected by calls that are made
during the game the officials go through
an exhaustive process just to get to the
NFL background checks you're looking at
your banking your banking statements
accounts your business partners all of
your relationships when they before they
hire an official in the NFL NFL Security
will go to the neighborhood and go door
to door and talk to the neighbors and
then and then it doesn't it doesn't stop
once you're in the NFL and continue to
look at bank accounts if you have an
official on Friday has ten dollars in
their checking account and then on
Monday they've got a hundred thousand
dollars that's a red flag right and so
they look at these things and they
monitor the lines because that will that
will really that strikes at the
Integrity of the game and and it just
can't happen before I let you go the
rule that you would remove is what
the rule that I would remove
um I I don't know if I necessarily
remove a rule I think I would I would I
would add a rule I do think we talked
about replay earlier I do think if we're
going to go down this path of reviewing
plays I think we need to review
defenseless player hits on defenseless
players I think we need to give give the
officials an opportunity
um if the game is so fast and it happens
we see it we see it every week we see it
every game where these calls and the
officials are getting one look at it
from their perspective they may get
blocked out so I think if we can give
them more tools uh I think that's
something that that I would be in favor
of
um you know adding adding a little bit
more to replay not going too far I don't
think we want to review everything but
those game changing 15-yard penalties I
think we can I think we can correct
those what about fumbling the ball out
of the end zone we yeah you know we we
actually did that in the spring league
in the XFL we said if you fumble the
ball out of the end zone
um you get to put the ball back at the
spot of the fumble and it didn't happen
until the last game of the year and we
brought it back to the spot of the
fumble and we thought everybody was
going to celebrate that and some people
were happy other people were like why
isn't that a Touchback and the problem
it was a player he was about a six yard
line and starting to celebrate a little
bit early and he got hit from behind the
ball went through uh the opponent's End
Zone and uh and there was no real
repercussions and and so I like that
being a Touchback I get it when the
running back is just reaching for the
goal line it just happens to Fumble it
at the last second and it hits the pylon
but I think the the goal line The End
Zone that sacred ground I think you
should you should have some some penalty
if you fumble into the Enzo how did the
officials get out of a stadium
are they is there a police escort is
there a great question great question
yes the officials have security so
whatever wherever they go they have a
security person that is assigned to them
that will that will get them the they
they come in a van it's not like they
have their own individual cars they come
in one van security they come into right
where the players come in where the
coaches come in those entrances they
have that security person or team that's
assigned to them that will get them from
the van walk them to the locker room be
with them whenever they need to if the
referee has to go to the the visiting
team locker room or the home team locker
room escort them and the same thing out
of the stadium and they get them to the
van and in many cases they have a police
escort out of the perimeter of the
stadium to get them on their way to
either the hotel or the airport wow
great stuff Dean thanks for joining us
and we'll talk to you during the season
you got it Dan thanks Dean blandino Fox
NFL rules analyst former NFL VP of
officiating